one welcome back and let's write some
more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem reverse integer even
though this is marked as an easy
question i would say that this is
definitely more of a medium question and
that's probably why this question has so
many different uh so many dislikes but i
don't think it's actually a bad problem
it's definitely good when it comes to
bit manipulation so we're given a signed
32-bit integer x the fact that it's
32-bit is very important here we want to
return
this integer x with all of its digits
being reversed and the only catch here
is if reversing this integer x causes
the value to go outside of the 32-bit
integer range which is this then
then we basically want to return 0 if
that's the case because we're working
with 32-bit integers if the integer
overflows then we want to return 0. and
this is the portion that's actually
going to make the the problem difficult
because we are working with 32-bit
integers and we cannot assume that we
can store 64-bit integers or anything
greater than 32-bits that's what makes
this question difficult i think because
if we just take a look at the standard
procedure that we would do take the
first example over here we have one two
three did you know we can chop off this
one's place digit pretty easily you can
do that by
modding this by 10. if we mod by 10
we're basically dividing this by 10
except we're getting the remainder which
is exactly what we want that's how you
get the ones place if i took 123 divided
by 10 what would be the remainder it
would be 3 of course right so then we
can get 3. so with this digit we want to
create a new integer right so we're
going to start our new integer just
being 3 right this is the result that
we're returning it's going to be three
let me you know write it down over here
three right then another operation we
can do on 123. now that we've processed
this one's place we don't really care
about the ones place anymore right we
don't care about this three now we want
to look at the next digit right so how
can we basically chop this digit off
well it's pretty easy you basically take
123 divide it by 10 when i say divide
we're not doing decimal division we're
doing integer division so
when you do integer division we round
towards zeros if we divide this by 10 we
will get 12 because we're rounding down
we're rounding towards zero so now we
have 12. we're going to basically repeat
that exact same step that we just did
over here basically now we're going to
take 12
mod it by 10 and now we're going to get
the ones place which is 2 right that's
the digit we were looking for so now we
want to take this 2 and add it over here
right now how can we do that well we
have a digi we have a value three so
let's take three multiply it by ten what
do we get we get thirty right why did we
multiply it by ten because we wanted to
shift this three to the left by one
because now we're going to take this 30
add 2 to it why are we adding 2 because
that's the digit that we just computed
up above right so we add 2 to 30 now we
get 32 right so we've almost we're
almost done reversing this integer right
if you take a look over here we started
with 123 we've reversed the first two
digits right but now we want to reverse
the last one which is one and that'll be
pretty easy we'll just continue the
steps that we've just done up above so
then we'll at the end we'll have 321
and then we'll return that which is
exactly what we wanted to do and believe
it or not we can do this exact same
procedure on negative numbers and it
works out the exact same so that's the
good thing the only downside is we
haven't covered what are we going to do
if the digits overflow so let me kind of
explain that to you this range that we
have to kind of meet oh in the
description they say that if the value
goes out of bounds so take a look at the
left they say if it goes out of bounds
from this range then return 0. now what
is the value negative 2 or 2 to the
power of 31 negative right negative 2 to
the power 31 what is that value well you
can see over here this is that full
value these are the digits what is 2 to
the power of 31 minus 1 this is that
value so what if we had a example that
looked basically was too
large right what if the value was too
large to fit what if the value was
actually larger than the max value that
we can possibly have what if the value
was two one four seven what if the value
was the exact same as this except plus
one you can see that this is the exact
same value except i added one so this is
an eight instead of a seven and actually
what if the input value was this
basically what if the input value was
the reverse of the max digit plus one
right
let's say this was our input value right
and let's say we reversed it if we
reversed it this is the reversed value
up above right this is what we would get
but what we know is this integer is
actually too
large this integer is greater than the
one up above so this would not even fit
into memory so we would need to return
zero now how could we detect that this
integer overflows without actually
calculating it right because we can't
have this digit this digit is impossible
to have in 32 bits so how would we
detect it without actually building this
number without actually taking this and
reversing it all the way to here well
that's the trick that i'm going to show
you we actually are are going to reverse
this input digit by digit except for the
last digit we're not going to reverse
we're not going to add the last digit
yet what we're going to do is once we've
reversed this right we have all but the
last digit we're going to check okay is
this value exactly equal to
this value basically all everything from
the max digit except the last digit how
are we going to actually get this
basically we can take the max digit and
divide it by 10 right because dividing
by 10 we'll take the ones place digit
and chop it off right so if we do that
like this we're going to check okay is
is our reversed integer equal to this
one yes it is right it's exactly equal
in this case okay and then the next
question we're gonna ask ourselves is
okay we're trying to also we're now
trying to add another digit we add the
ones place digit okay so how do we know
then if if the resulting integer is
going to be greater than this max
integer up above how do we know that
well all we have to do since we know
that this is equal to this now all we
have to do is compare the ones place is
eight
greater than
this integer we have over here which is
seven in this case it is greater than it
right so then we're not actually going
to take this eight digit and add it to
here add it to this entire integer we're
actually going to return zero
immediately so that's one trick that
we're gonna basically to basically to
detect if we go out of bounds and
basically i just showed you the example
of what we would do for positive
integers the exact same is basically
going to be true for negative integers
except instead of checking if this digit
is greater than the ones place of the
max negative integer or the minimum
negative integer we're not going to
check if it's greater we're going to
check if it's less than because this is
a negative number right so that's one
way we could detect if we did go out of
bounds another way we can actually check
is
taking away this final digit right this
one's place digit and taking away this
one's place digit again and we do know
how to do that in the code so i won't
explain it but if we were comparing all
of these digits right and we were
comparing all of these digits and let's
say we knew that yes we are about to add
another digit we know for sure we're
going to add another digit then what
we're going to ask is or is this portion
down here that i have squared up is this
greater than this over here right for
example over here that we have a value
we have a value 2 followed by 8
different digits right so suppose this
value over here that i have written over
here it wasn't 2 followed by 8 digits it
was a 3 0
0 0 0 0 followed by 8 0's right then we
know for sure this is actually larger
than this integer i have up above since
we know this is larger and let's say
we're adding another zero to it so now
we have nine zeros then we know for sure
it's gonna be greater than the max
integer up above because that max
integer starts with a two followed by
nine digits right we know for sure this
is gonna be greater so basically that's
how we're going to compare it i know
this sounds confusing right but to put
it simply if we compare this with this
up above and we know that this is
greater than we know we're out of bounds
and then we're going to again have to
return zero i know this seems really
complicated but let me show you the code
and it's actually gonna be probably even
more simple this is definitely why i
would say this is more of a medium
problem not an easy problem okay so now
let's get into the code and i already
wrote out the code because i think it's
going to be more easy to understand if
you can kind of see the entire structure
written out so in most languages you can
find the max integer and minimum integer
in 32 bits right this is the max integer
this is the minimum integer and i have
those coded up above in python the math
it kind of works out a little bit
differently compared to most languages
but i'm basically doing the with the
following while loop i'm doing what i
explained earlier in the video so we
have our result initially zero right
we're passed in some integer x so while
this integer x is not zero let's
continue the loop right now we're in the
looping phase we're going through each
digit of x what we want to do right just
like i mentioned earlier we want to take
x and mod it by 10. now you would you're
probably wondering why can't i just take
x and mod it by 10 why do i need this
helper function or whatever uh basically
because python is kind of dumb it does
some unexpected behavior negative 1
modded by 10 should not be 9 in most
cases but python is a little bit
different than most languages in most
languages you can just do the mod
operator but we're doing math f mod to
get that digit in python once we have
that digit we're clear right then we
want to take x and divide it by 10.
you're wondering why can't we just
divide it by 10 well python's a little
bit weird so
we're doing we're we're dividing it by
10 and then casting it back to an
integer to make sure that we can round
towards zero in most languages you won't
have to do this you can just take x
divided by 10 but python's a little bit
weird so excuse that so then we we've we
have the digit and we took x and we
chopped off the digit so that's good
next we want to do the stuff that i just
mentioned actually right so i want to
take that result right we have a digit
we want to add it to the result but you
can see i'm doing a couple if statements
before i actually execute this line down
here where i'm actually taking that
digit and adding it to the result right
result multiplied by 10 and then add
that digit which is what we discussed
earlier but before i do this i have to
make sure that this is not going to
overflow how can i guarantee it's not
going to overflow well if we take the
current result and we take the max value
divided by 10 why are we taking this max
value up above and dividing up by 10
because we don't want to look at that
last digit yet because we can't look at
that last digit until we know for sure
that this value is not going to overflow
so we're going to compare every other
digit so if this result is greater than
max divided by 10 then we're going to
return 0 because we know it's going to
overflow regardless of what that digit
is it's going to overflow because uh the
result the result is already larger than
max divided by 10. so that's one case
the other case is if the result is
exactly equal to max divided by 10 right
if it's exactly equal to this max
portion except the last digit and if if
that's if that's true and if the digit
is greater than 7 where did i get 7 from
well basically this is max modded by 10.
if you take this max integer mod it by
10 you're gonna get the ones place which
is seven so if the digit is greater than
seven and this previous portion executed
as true then we're going to return zero
so that's basically the case if the
resulting integer is going to be too
large the bottom if statement is the
exact same thing except if the resulting
integer was going to be too small if it
was going to be smaller than the minimum
integer we have up above so if that was
the case then we'd return 0 as well and
if if those don't execute then we can go
ahead and finally take that digit and
add it to the result and then we can
when once the while loop is done
executing if the result has not
overflowed then we can return that
result so that was a lot of information
but i hope that these if statements are
finally starting to make sense and the
good thing is once you run the code it
is about as efficient as it can possibly
be so i hope that this video was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon thanks for
watching